let's go straight to the questions
minister lavrov announced today that
russia will introduce counter sanctions
against germany and france following the
alleged navalny poisoning
lavrov said that we have all the grounds
to believe that the poisoning took place
either on the plane that took him from
holmes to germany
or that it happened when he was already
in germany what does the kremlin have to
say about it
and let's just not call him a patient
but nevertheless
he is a berlin patient the berlin
patient is a different person
first of all it is not reasonable to
think that lavrov and the kremlin would
have different opinions
because after all sergey lavrov is the
minister of foreign affairs
and russia's foreign policy is
determined by the president
that is why we work in sync like a
person's head and hands
as for the counter sanctions against
france and germany it was inevitable
and there is a strong case for the
principle of reciprocity
in this instance and of course it was
highly unlikely that russia
would leave it unanswered all the more
so because a
the reason for these sanctions was more
than doubtful
against russia yes for the initial
sanctions
and b the sanctions were unprecedented
or relatively unprecedented
top members of the president's executive
office were put on the list
on doubtful grounds so our response is a
no-brainer
well what kind of response would that be
for example germany put sergey kiriyanka
on the list
what are we going to do then some
assistant to angela merkel from
traveling to the olmska region in
siberia was he or she very eager to go
there in the first place
well it is hardly possible to find
kirienko's equal
true but in any case technically it is
easy to find an official of the same
rank
what do we really think about this
poisoning and was there poisoning at all
we have already talked a lot about it
frankly speaking
i would not like to continue this
discussion at all but nevertheless
these are just questions i'm not
challenging anyone's views
okay let us proceed from hard facts a
person
lost consciousness on an airplane the
person was treated in an
omsk hospital in the intensive care unit
since there was an emergency situation
during the flight which caused an
emergency landing and so on
then of course all the necessary
investigative activities were performed
by default
all the tests that were taken in the
hospital in that intensive care unit
all the tests that were done as part of
these investigative activities
showed no signs of poisoning whatsoever
at the request of the patient's family
the authorities undertook special
measures
to assist him in traveling abroad why
special measures
because he was not allowed to go
anywhere under law he was under a travel
ban
of course under law he could not go
anywhere but on the other hand this is
his usual situation
and in fact after the doctors dropped
their reservations
decisive reservations against
transportation an order was sent to
remove these restrictions and let them
go
who sent the order well the president
explained it
the president talked about it himself it
would have been difficult
to do so without that order because he
was subject to the travel ban
after all that is uh personally resolved
the issue
he did not resolve it he ordered to
provide all possible assistance
it was the doctors who made the decision
it was their call
here is what happened next next the
berlin hospital reported that tests were
carried out by a special laboratory of
the bundeswehr
and some substances were found
indicating that the patient was poisoned
by novichok
then russia sent a request no answer
we sent a second request again no answer
what request about the substance we took
the tests the entire
so russia has not received any official
answers
no then we found out that with the
family's consent
more tests were done and the tests were
sent to laboratories
in other capitals
which ones stockholm well somewhere in
sweden at least
we don't know exactly where the lab is
located and france
why i do not know why
you have to ask either a the patient or
b german officials
again none of our requests came back
with an answer
moreover they started to give
contradictory statements
it turned out it was not novichok it was
a certain substance which is not
included in the list of banned
substances of the opcw
but may fall into the novichok group in
other words
it is a kind of poison and not a poison
at the same time
both are poison and not a poison and
both banned and not banned
both detectable and non-detectable only
for some reason
it is not detectable in russia but is
detectable in germany and sweden
overall there are more questions than
answers and
in response to our questions our foreign
counterparts
those who introduced those very
sanctions made contradictory statements
so we are where we are what is russia's
stance
we are still interested in the
investigation of all the circumstances
of what happened
we want to know the truth so we said
please help us
if you have information that we do not
have please share it with us
but no one wanted to cooperate sometimes
it seems that the patient
does not want that truth to be out
himself sometimes it seems the patient
is not that sick there are a lot of
questions about his illness too
and if he is ill we need to know how bad
and whether his disease can fade and
come back
well you have to agree that there are
more questions than answers
this is why we have what we have we've
heard quite tough statements about the
russian federation from berlin
we do not agree with these statements we
are still interested in finding out the
circumstances of what happened
but unfortunately our counterparts
remain deaf
to our requests
aren't these harsh statements just a
part of the diplomatic protocol
correct me if i am wrong but germany
itself is the main victim because of
sanctions imposed for instance against
the nordstrom 2 project
well nordstrom 2 is an international
project it is an international project
which is actually a
in the interests of the joint venture
itself there are purely commercial
interests
b in the interests of those who will
pump gas through this pipeline
meaning in our interests yes and in the
interests of those who will receive this
gas
that is northern germany northern europe
of course
everything is absolutely clear here the
position is absolutely clear
the project is a international and b
commercial
and c no matter who says what even
despite the periodic appeal
of the spot market nothing other than
pipeline gas
can ensure europe's energy security why
is that
because the spot market is quite
volatile and because it is subject to a
variety of factors
such as transportation safety
reliability of liquefaction equipment
etc
in many countries it is also dominated
by factors that have to do with the
current political landscape in lng
exporting countries
finally there is the issue of climate
change which will affect
transportation boots modes of
transportation etc
in other words the spot market is much
less stable than the pipeline gas
market where russia happens to be far
above the competition
not only is this market stable but is
overall cheaper and more reliable
it is designed for the long term which
allows consumers of this particular
energy resource
to calculate development plans far into
the future
does this mean that you indirectly or
all of us collectively as russians
are accusing the us of trying to drive
us out of the european market
by any means available by means that our
dishonest and unscrupulous
this is no question unfair competition
on the part of the us
no question none at all let's be
perfectly clear
u.s ambassadors to europe's capitals
have no qualms about inviting or even
summoning heads of companies
and leaders of governments to lecture
them like a teacher scolding his pupils
about the russian pipeline project and
why it should be aborted
and what does america offer in return
perhaps we should have negotiated
something with the americans and divided
up the market
look this is economic competition which
is a game you play
by the rules no political interference
but it never really works that way does
it
it does sometimes but we still have
international trade law which includes
trade and energy resources
oil and gas trade is subject to certain
rules oil is a commodity after all
as soon as someone relies on politics or
uses state power in some domain in order
to put pressure on potential competitors
well that's too far and we don't do that
no we don't i see we never do that
never sure we can make use of our
competitive advantages like natural
wealth technology
or our superiority in terms of
infrastructure but that doesn't mean
that we pressure someone into giving up
their commercially profitable projects
speaking of the us let's move on to the
presidential election
all right these elections seem to have
gone almost unnoticed by the kremlin
i mean it feels as if the kremlin
doesn't even care who wins trump or
biden
as of right now it looks like joe biden
meaning the democratic party is on track
for victory
what does the kremlin think about all
this and what are russia's prospects
either way
as president putin put it several years
ago it's none of our business
the americans clearly don't think that
way
first we will respect the choice of the
american people whatever it is
second we are willing to work with any
future u.s president
whomever the americans choose and third
naturally we would be much happier with
a president
who'd be willing to put at least some
effort into reanimating u.s russia
relations
also fourth we have never interfered
and will never interfere in america's
internal affairs
but that goes both ways we will never
let america interfere in our domestic
affairs
either this is our unchanging principle
and this is what our president has
expressed repeatedly speaking at
international forums in bilateral
conversations
etc let's talk first about interference
and let's discuss whether the united
states actually tried to meddle in our
domestic affairs whether this is so
evident
and let's also talk about the us
accusing us of interfering in their
internal affairs
in the previous election season for
example for four years this story has
handicapped president trump in many ways
preventing him from
performing his duties as president and
finally when it comes to u.s russia
relations
what can we expect from a democrat in
the white house from the democratic
party in power
over the past 10 years our legislation
has matured and evolved in terms of
preventing foreign powers
from interfering in our internal affairs
we have set up all kinds of watchdog
systems
in multiple areas allowing us to
minimize the threat of foreign
interference
for example
take the restrictions imposed on
foreigners with respect to owning
media companies in russia or the foreign
agent regulations that we've introduced
in fact these have all been subject to
legislative change over recent years
sure some of our own champions of
american democracy
our own you mean from among russians yes
here in russia
you know very well that we have very
vocal people
who kept complaining about violations of
human rights or saying that entire
sectors of the economy
would stop developing nothing of that
sort ever happened
but we were able to dramatically reduce
the risk of foreign interference
do we have any proven cases of u.s
interfering in our domestic affairs
lots of them for example
well if you told me in advance i'd
probably be able to recall some of the
stories of the past 10 years
well discounting the story about the spy
rock
ah the infamous spy rock the method used
only
proves that scouting and spying is one
of the world's oldest professions
no idea if that's true however spying
used to be our president's profession
and in the case of the spy rock those
were actual spies
you probably remember that even before
the prosecutor general's office would
compile entire databases of money
transfers from the us
to various public organizations etc i
remember all of that
being reported to the president in fact
we made most of the information public
there are lots of examples of that sort
the money transfers were
viewed as interfering with russian
politics naturally
because those were ngos that engaged in
political activities right
exactly and don't forget the constant
evaluating of our domestic political
processes
incessant criticism accusations of human
rights violations
disapproval of our election practices
given recent developments i don't think
the americans have the right to
criticize anyone else's elections really
of course they can but at the very least
we've been hearing all these things all
the time
and what is it if not intervention into
internal affairs
has russia ever intervened in united
states internal affairs
no never under no circumstances it
hasn't
so we didn't buy any ads on facebook as
they've been accusing us and neither did
we
i'm sure someone did place some
commercial ads
facebook has a whole sales policy for
and there surely were some people from
russia who made use of it
that's nothing out of the ordinary it's
not however
you mean that they're probably worth
some private buyers from russia who paid
for such as for their own purposes
of course some people completely legit
who just purchased some ads
but russia has a state
has been broadcasting in the united
states for some time
exactly but our american counterparts
seem to consider it
a direct intervention in their internal
affairs
so this way when rt and broadcast isn't
in the us it's intervention
while when cnn is broadcasting and they
did so through russia's national media
group by the way
so what are we to expect from democrats
in the white house if it's the democrats
of course
from whoever is in the white house i'd
say i'm positive we will see a
biden-harris administration
we don't have the official results yet
but most likely
until the official results are announced
but i have no right to do that
especially since the president gave
orders to wait for the official results
and to congratulate the president-elect
only upon the announcement
is this how we are supporting trump in a
way or are we just following the
diplomatic protocol
absolutely not we're just waiting
politely
we do not comment on the u.s election or
on the current situation in the united
states
we're simply waiting until america is
ready to announce the newly elected
president
not the american media but the american
nation
what was it like to work with biden he
served as vice president during obama's
presidency
so we know him well you know him
of course he met with his boss yes so it
was mostly about building dialogue with
president obama
and it wasn't easy not at all what do
you mean
especially obama's last six months in
office
why there were a lot of disagreements
that led to russian-american relations
eventually deteriorating during
president
trump's term what was it that happened
between our countries during barack
obama's presidency that after the
russian-american relations had been
officially reset it all went crumbling
down
um
well your question calls for a detailed
analysis
of russian-american relations but in
essence it's all very simple
if we look back at where our bilateral
relations started in the first place
it looks like washington's plan was to
keep russia's economy in development
around the level it sank to in the 1990s
as a resource colony that was the russia
they were comfortable with
in other words what kind of russia was
that
the kind of russia that's easy to
control the kind of russia that has no
voice on the international scene
the kind of russia that has no economic
social political or federal potential to
claim a voice
the kind of russia that wouldn't be able
to say okay guys
we have conditions such as mutual
respect and mutual interests
so as soon as russia began to change
starting with the early 2000s
washington began to feel uneasy about it
as russia grew stronger
i'm not saying it was getting as strong
as it used to be but as it was getting
stronger
it was making them more and more
concerned
that's what historically predetermined
the trajectory of our bilateral
relations
and what we have now obviously russia
wasn't ready to accept
any kind of relations except those based
on the principle of equal partnership
neither was it ready to make concessions
and let any red lines be crossed in the
area of national interests
indeed as i recall it closer to the end
of the second term president obama was
expressing the following views
why would we have a dialogue on equal
terms with a country that has the
economy the size of spain
i don't know whose feelings he hurt more
by saying this russia or spain but
obviously the rhetoric of inequality was
there as president obama was on his way
out of the office
but all this rotation that the kremlin
that russia was apparently causing
i think there should have been some
reason for it don't you think so well
regardless of the size of the economy
russia is a country that has a special
position in the world
because of its enormousness
enormousness it's incomprehensibility
because of its geopolitical significance
most probably
because of all these things because it
supports a multi-polar world
because it's double-headed as the
imperial eagle on its coat of arms
because of all of this
but no matter how you put it it sounds
like you're saying russia's bipolar
no why you said double headed but each
of the two heads
works just fine right of course in this
sense president obama's wish was like
that of the dostoyevsky character who
said
yes the russian man is broad too broad
indeed i'd have him narrower
he definitely wished to have russia
narrower we don't want to be made
narrower political analyst alexander
bonov said once that the reason for
the conflict between russia and the
united states is that russia is the only
other country in the world capable of
protecting not only itself
but its allies and that is what's
causing such protest and disagreement
that we see in america's foreign policy
towards russia
would you agree with that i don't think
we should narrow it all down to
russia-us relations
we're witnessing how a unipolar world
order is transforming into a multipolar
one
it's a very painful process that sole
center of power that used to reign alone
is now pushing back against the change
consciously or subconsciously i don't
know
it's fighting this process the formerly
dominant center
finds it extremely hard to adapt to this
new world order
that's why the whole system of
international law is breaking down
international institutions are crumbling
as well there are those who are trying
to challenge international institutions
day and night
the mandates of some institutions get
undermined
while others grow in importance and some
of them actually cease playing any role
at all
which ones let's not go into that the
iwan
the un has always been the only
universal international institution
that we can't do without it's the un and
the security council with the five
nuclear weapon states
that hold veto power i think you know
vladimir putin's position on that
issue the un is the cornerstone of
global security
coming back to russia possibly being the
only country except the us that can
protect someone besides itself
let's talk about the conflicts between
azerbaijan and armenia
as well as russia's role in it has seen
absolutely dramatic shifts
armenia had to abandon some sizable
areas which are thought to be in its
full possession for decades
for decades you thought that way because
that's how russia played its role
as armenia's ally now russia hasn't been
supporting armenia in that conflict
in any significant way at least from an
outside perspective
actually when i scroll down my facebook
feed i see half of my armenian friends
complaining about russia's betrayal
what does the kremlin think about that
it's no secret that baku backed by
turkey
announced that it considered a military
solution as a way to solve the problem
in the gona karabakh
it is because of this stance that
azerbaijan launched a military operation
this military intervention happened
after the osce minsk
group russia in particular had been
proposing various formulas that could
end the conflict
for many years there have been several
formulas and all the parties to the
negotiations are well aware of them
unfortunately for some reason none of
them worked
why is that there were reasons
both sides are at fault unfortunately
there were reasons why those formulas
haven't been put into action
if they had been say even two years ago
and this war
and all the bloodshed could have been
avoided thousands of young armenians and
azerbaijanis
wouldn't have died what were those
formulas
i don't think i can elaborate on any of
them especially now
i don't think it's necessary so the
topic is off-limits
yes here's what i can tell you none of
the minsk group co-chairman
shared baku's stance the trio had been
insisting in a well-argued manner
that the only possible solution to that
conflict is diplomacy
that's what we all had been saying to
persuade
you remember that soon after hostilities
erupted
three leaders putin trump and macron
made a rather unprecedented and a very
important statement
france had been working on that problem
and washington too
all within the same framework i think
that contributed a lot to the consensus
that enabled putin
alive and passion to end the conflict
the people who criticize russia in your
facebook feed have absolutely no grounds
to do that
president putin said unequivocally that
russia never forgot
about his obligations as member of csto
and if an allies territory was under
attack if armenia's territory
was under any threat then russia would
surely do everything within its power
to protect its ally that's what our
president said
the criticism you've heard is absolutely
unfounded and
unfair
perhaps armenians expected russia to
deploy troops
did we have the right to do that
no we did get the right to deploy a
peacekeeping mission
but only after the warring parties
agreed to that
the peacekeepers were ordered to stand
at the separation line
as for sending its military forces
especially to karabakh
russia did not have any such right by
international law
russia continues to abide by all
relevant resolutions of the un security
council
i don't think we can call this a peace
agreement because we don't know yet how
it's going to play out
let's say it's a quasi piece an
agreement between two warring parties
that has been brokered mainly by russia
and president
this agreement triggered quite a
response did you expect that azerbaijan
would resolutely claim that it won
and that loss of armenians would take to
the streets to protest
i am in no position to comment on either
the azerbaijani's response or the
armenian's reaction
it would be foolish of me to do that i
can only say that i appreciate the wise
choice the politicians made
which politicians
thanks to vladimir putin's efforts they
signed a joint statement
and ended the hostilities stopped the
bloodshed
could you please elaborate on president
putin's role in this agreement how did
he facilitate it
he played a critical role the signing of
that agreement was preceded by many days
of tireless work
sometimes almost around the clock it was
president putin
who did that he was on the phone all the
time making numerous calls
again he'd been doing that for days
what was turkey's role
i think that's a good question for you
since you're an expert on turkey
you know turkey has been consistently
supporting a military operation scenario
a forceful resolution to the
nagorno-karabakh conflict
we had a very different position on that
issue it continues to be
like that however that didn't preclude
us
from closely cooperating on all levels
including the level of presidents
i think you're aware that putin and
erdogan maintain
continuous dialogue even though russia
and turkey have their
differences this relationship between
the two leaders
allows us to combine our efforts when
necessary to facilitate
the resolution of various regional
problems
you know it's really not that clear to
an ordinary person for example right now
we're talking about imposing sanctions
on say one of angel merkel's deputies
as a response while our people believe
that our relations with germany are
great
with turkey we've seen an endless string
of confrontations
take that time our ambassador was killed
or the mig
and now this war in the caucasus the
south caucuses all of this happened with
turkey instigated
or directly taking part in it and
president erdogan is personally
responsible
so what is it about our relations that's
so warm and friendly what are they based
on
in many respects our interests are
aligned it's vital for both russia
and turkey that the situation in our
region is stable
predictable and peaceful
well that's not very clear russia and
turkey have a lot of mutual interest in
terms of trade
and economic cooperation as well as
investment cooperation
it serves both moscow's and anchorage
interests
to work together
still you just said it yourself that
turkey was in favor of a military
scenario in the south caucasus
yes and the turkish president said that
and yet now you say they want peace
world peace how could they be an
advocate of world peace then
in this case turkey believes mistakenly
in our view
that peace can be established through
the use of force
in this respect we disagree had
president putin
had any direct contact while the
ceasefire was being negotiated
and if so what kind of contact was it uh
there were of course contacts regarding
the situation
you know that as a result it was decided
that a monitoring center will be set
up it will be located in azerbaijan but
outside of nagorno-karabakh
the center will monitor how the
ceasefire is observed
the same ceasefire that on the ground is
maintained and observed through the
efforts of
russian peacekeepers
how is the russian government going to
control the situation within the
expatriate community
between the two communities i mean the
millions of armenians living in russia
and several million azerbaijanis also
living in russia it's obvious that there
are going to be clashes based on
ethnicity
at least
no it's absolutely not obvious and not
inevitable
i completely disagree with you there
first of all as you probably know the
number of armenians living in russia
is about the same as the number of them
living in armenia or even slightly
higher
than in actual armenia yes of course
as you also know most of these armenians
and most of these azerbaijanis
are well respected members of russian
society
of our unique russian society a society
that embraces
many ethnicities and faiths successful
individuals both armenians and
azerbaijanis
illustrate the fact that russia is truly
a land of opportunities
they are all responsible well-respected
and responsible
members of our society who fully
understand that on
russian soil they have to follow the
laws of the russian federation
as you know in russia any kind of
hate-fuelled behavior
or something like that towards an ethnic
group is against the law
it's absolutely unacceptable in our
country and our fellow citizens both
armenians and azerbaijanis
know this very well and actually behave
very
responsibly that sounded like a warning
no i'm just stating facts it's just a
fact
they really do behave very responsibly
you know there were some incidents
at the very beginning of the recent
tragic events
as you know
we put a stop to it very fast
let's talk about our helicopter that was
shot down by azerbaijan
what was the president's first immediate
reaction and why or rather
how was this conflict localized so fast
yes it's really awful it's a tragedy two
of our men
are dead you know of course how painful
it is for all of us
for military commanders and all our
servicemen and
probably russian people in general too
but in this case it was obvious that
azerbaijan
immediately reacted the president of
azerbaijan immediately
reacted and azerbaijan pledged to
conduct an independent
investigation into it and punish those
responsible
all of that made it possible for us to
accept their apology
of course as you know armenia and russia
are partners in the eurasian economic
community the csto we've been building
our relations with armenia
for centuries the same is true of our
ties with azerbaijan
we value our friendship our shared
history both with the people of
azerbaijan
and the people of armenia and it is this
kind of approach that allowed russia
to be an objective intermediary
do we value our friendship with the
people of belarus it's more than just a
friendship
it's like family is alexander lukashenko
family too
he is bella russian so you consider him
family
of course seriously my distant relatives
are from belarus
during the 26 or 27 years of his
presidency alexander lukashenko
consistently tried to rip off russia
he would ask us for money and then go to
china he would demand discounted gas
prices and then make a deal with the
americans
this has been happening throughout his
whole presidency why do we support
alexander kashenko so vehemently
it's not alexander lukashenko whom we
support
we support the legitimate president of a
nation that we consider to be our
brothers
we support the rule of law in this
brotherly nation for over 10 years
russia and the russian president
supported and indirectly subsidized
the belarusian economy it wasn't just
subsidizing and it wasn't indirect
because the whole belarusian economy is
just part of the russian economy
exactly and that of course is because we
are the closest of allies
we are two nations that are like
brothers and of course we value one
another
mr prescott but the same things were
said about the ukrainians a few years
ago
and we still think of ukraine as a
nation that we have family ties with
but we are no longer brothers no our
relations can no longer be qualified as
brotherly
because in recent years the country's
leadership put a lot of effort into
fostering
animosity towards russia in the
ukrainian people
but we don't think that this will lead
to a long-term immunity against russia
it can't last these antibodies will
disappear
really just like the coronavirus
antibodies these are
artificially implanted antibodies the
anti-russian sentiment
will pass the recent regional elections
prove my point the elections in ukraine
yes they show that the antibodies are
not all that strong
you know what i'm talking about but
let's go back to belarus
we can talk about protests being
ultimately unsuccessful etc
but hundreds of thousands took to the
streets in a very small country
only six million people actually live
there three million live outside belarus
hundreds continue to protest in
different cities
they continue to come out to protest
against president lukashenko
and none of the opposition leaders have
ever expressed any anti-russian views
unlike president lukashenko so why do we
keep supporting lukashanka
maybe it would make more sense to look
elsewhere i'm sure you've heard my
statements regarding this
i have answered questions about belarus
asked by journalists
and it was not just one statement or a
couple of statements
and i'm convinced that i have nothing to
add to those statements
but mr piskov no i have nothing to add
my explanations
were thorough you can easily look them
up of course we can look them up but
russians are very sensitive to these
situations
they see it on tv and they are concerned
different people with different views
are concerned but all these people are
against alexander lukashenko
some think that belarus is our territory
russia's border is near breast
and that's where we should position our
intermediate range and short-range
missiles
others think that it should be a free
country independent from russia and
definitely not under lukashenka
and there is a third group they see
alexander lukashenko with an empty
machine gun
no ammunition his son walking alongside
through an empty
square dressed in military uniform and
this image bothers them
don't you think that this friendship is
not doing any good to our image and
ratings
people may have completely different
views the key principle for us
is legitimacy under international law
whatever happens has to be in line with
law
it is the people of belarus who have to
ensure legitimacy
there should be no outside interference
you mentioned international law
but most countries have not recognized
the outcome of the election in belarus
also the russian president signed into
law a bill on the supremacy of domestic
legislation
and the russian constitution over this
so-called international law
so why do we always hark on about
international law
i am referring to the provisions that do
not run counter to the russian
constitution
why do we always make references to
international law
that's the most essential point of
reference true a country may not
recognize the election outcome
however no country has the mandate
provided by international law
to deem an election legitimate or
illegitimate no country neither the eu
nor germany france poland and so on they
simply do not have the mandate
does it mean that only alexander
lukashenko has this mandate
well they have the central election
commission he has the sole position to
exercise this mandate let us not go into
detail
i've shared with you our key principle
let's go back to item number one of the
agenda
the covet 19 pandemic the exact number
of cases in russia is unknown
moscow mayor sergey sabanyan recently
admitted that a 25
surge in cases basically in a couple of
weeks time would push health care in
moscow to peak capacity
well if that's the situation in moscow
we also know that what's happening
across russian regions
take the olmsk region for example when
an ambulance was not able to have
patients admitted to a clinic
and drove them to the buildings of the
regional administration it is disgraced
for the regional authorities
but i feel that no lessons were learned
how did the kremlin learn about the
pandemic
whose expert judgment did you take into
account and what's next you had the
disease yourself along with your wife
and you had antibodies
you portrayed a fair picture but it is a
gloomy picture
you forgot to tell the audience about
the monumental effort
by our government in the past six months
about the mortality rate which is
far better than in other countries about
the medications
you were supposed to say that you should
have mentioned it
i will definitely now that you brought
up medication moscow is seeing a
shortage
but it is true
here's my comment indeed the pressure on
the healthcare system is enormous
in some regions it's beyond their
capacity after the first outbreak in the
spring
which slowly continued into the summer
it was extremely difficult it was
extremely difficult
it was a time when we had to scramble
for brand new treatments
protocols and to test them we had to add
new equipment
to re-equip hospital beds and so on
we spent the summer creating a backstop
to make sure we can handle any repeat of
the surges
we now have this buffer we have extra
hospitals extra beds
well equipped including with oxygen
we've procured extra ventilators
there is no shortage of ppe anymore it
is not an issue
i am referring to the gear for the
doctors
yes people know what ppe stands for
right you say there are no medications
indeed some places
quite sincere on this one absolutely it
is only appropriate
that i'm concerned about us as a nation
whenever i put out another film
people start dogging me with messages
that i only show the fairyland of moscow
and life outside moscow is completely
different story
moscow is different that's true moscow
is definitely several steps ahead of the
rest of russia in some aspects
it is several steps ahead of europe the
hospitals moscow built here in the
spring the mobile hospitals in
particular
are unprecedented absolutely
even germany has nothing like the kobet
19 hospital that was built in moscow
last spring
thanks to moscow mayor saban and his
deputy raccoon's efforts but we all look
at the rest of the country
they all had the same money and the same
possibilities the president said many
times they can use money from any fund
in order to fight the pandemic
and nonetheless we see that russia's
regions are experiencing huge problems
with medical care now
there was a tragic incident recently in
the region of khakasa there's an
absolutely unacceptable situation in
australia
and our people see this yes it's true
that there have been problems with
medical care in some regions
some of them critical and indeed
unacceptable
it's impossible to hide things like that
these days
the federal authorities have been
responding to such cases in a timely
manner
the military hospital was deployed in
calcasia within 48 hours
since the incident on the president's
orders
you know that the government has put
together a special mobile core of
medical professionals
several hundreds of them travel across
the country to provide help on site
both with advice and protocols and by
stepping in
they address such challenges and help
solve problems
the thing is that this pandemic has been
such a huge and
unprecedented challenge that some
problems are just inevitable
when did we realize the scope of the
challenge
i think the entire world realized it
more or less at the same time
when did the president realize it
clearly well the president
i'm sure you saw it yourself since last
spring the president has been working
almost 24 7. he had meetings every day
and all that anti-crisis measures were
developed to help our economy to
mitigate the losses that have been
inevitable because of the pandemic
i'm sure he realized it all immediately
it's a different thing now though
there was this sort of hope that it
won't get as bad as it was last spring
of course i wasn't sure there wouldn't
be any second wave and now we see that
it's getting even tougher than it was in
spring
so getting back to the president so
where did this idea of developing a
vaccine in russia come from who pitched
it
the gamalia research institute i see so
director ginsberg approached you or did
he approach the president how did it all
happen
no first of all quite a number of
research centers and laboratories
began working on vaccine development
on the president's orders to start with
they did it because it's their job
and yes the government ordered it too
because it was clear from the very start
through the input from epidemiologists
that we can't take on the pandemic
without
successful vaccination so relevant
research began from the very start
and some of these labs made a
breakthrough the first vaccine that was
ready was the one you know
as sputnik veg by the gamaliel research
institute
yes indeed that's how we got it and it's
indeed a very good vaccine that we hope
you didn't try it on yourself i didn't
because unfortunately
i got to try the natural form of
coronavirus on myself
how are you feeling by the way not great
can you tell us more
i was sick what were the symptoms the
symptoms are like you have some strange
flu
we had all experienced the flu before
this is an unusual kind
what was unusual about it you have a
headache but it is an unusual headache
muscle pain also feels different and
then you get all these strange
sensations in the lungs
it's difficult to breathe a pneumonia
that is not really pneumonia
it is basically thrombosis pulmonary
thrombosis
you know everything of course i think at
this point the average
russian is like a medical school
graduate when it comes to virology
i hope not otherwise we will definitely
not get qualified doctors who can treat
us
but in any case it's long inflammation
thrombosis or no thrombosis
yes and losing the sense of smell and
taste completely was a
very unique sensation your wife's
symptoms weren't as severe right
she was only sick for about three days
she also lost the sense of smell and
taste
but for five or seven days this lasted
longer in my case
but as far as feeling sick it was only
about three days for her
we've heard and the president confirmed
several times that his daughter got this
vaccine
and she had something to do with the
development of the gamalia vaccine is
that true
of course not i mean his daughter chose
the vaccine after what do you mean
does she have options like a storage
shelter no it was during phase two of
the clinical trials
they were looking for volunteers and she
volunteered volunteered yes of course
and now after phase two russia claims
and the president said that we
registered this vaccine
do you think that maybe was premature
since we didn't exactly follow the
guidelines and wait until the third
phase
expedited registration is allowed if the
government makes that decision
it is possible to register a vaccine
based on the results of the first two
phases
but phase three will still be completed
and that
is what's happening now with the gamalia
vaccine there are certain procedures in
place for these situations
and such procedures exist in many
countries many countries are also using
the expedited registration mechanism
nevertheless phase three of the clinical
trials for an american vaccine concluded
yesterday
the expedited the third phase but in
expedited registration of the vaccine
it will happen in a few days so there is
really no difference
it's basically the same do we understand
how effective the vaccine is does the
kremlin have this understanding do you
believe in what you are told
first of all the kremlin can't be the
judge of the vaccine's effectiveness
so you believe what the experts tell you
right yes we absolutely trust russian
virologists
experts at the gamalia research
institute who have published the results
of their studies just recently
94 effective 92 is it 92
yes 92 which is two percent more
effective than pfizer's vaccine
that's possible of course they claim 90
effectiveness it's quite likely yes
about 40 000 people have taken part in
the vaccine trials however for many
there was no blind choice the placebo or
the vaccine
which is the usual way of administering
vaccines that are tested they simply get
the vaccine shots
and the gamalay institute acknowledged
that openly so quite a few people in the
executive and legislative branches of
the government have actually been
vaccinated
what is your take on this it does not
look like the participants in vaccine
trials it's real vaccination
no it's participation in the trials too
first of all we are talking about
participation in vaccine trials at the
stage
when the vaccine is still being tested
this is point number one
and people volunteer to take part in
these trials this is point number two
you see the results of these trials
involving all these people become part
of the
big data set part of the big data set
related to vaccine testing
so these trials are included in the
vaccine studies results right of course
why has the president not been
vaccinated yet you know that the
president has given high praise to both
the sputnik v and the vaccine developed
by vector
he also has high hopes for and what
about the third vaccine
for the third vaccine but when he
himself decides to get vaccinated he
will inform us
okay yesterday moscow saw 6 500 new
cases
and a record high number of coronavirus
related deaths was recorded yesterday in
the country
no yesterday we had fewer than it must
be today
below 6 000. no yesterday we had 6100 i
think
no the day before yesterday we had 6
000. no i'm pretty sure
well we had this figure at some point
but not yesterday and not the day before
yesterday
i won't argue with you i can look up the
figures in the emergency response team's
records right now
in any case we are dealing with very
high numbers here have we reached the
peak of the pandemic now or
are we still headed in that direction
and what do you think of the lockdown
for now we have the statements by sergey
sabian and president putin
who both said that the mobilization
level of russia's healthcare system
even given the current setbacks we have
already discussed today
the level of mobilization allows us to
implement
restrictive measures designed to bring
down the number of infections in a way
that
won't kill the economy and at the same
time these measures can be readjusted to
specific regions of the country because
back in the spring
governors were granted special authority
to do this
but surely there has to be a way to
supervise these special powers it is
clear that governors are no experts in
anti-epidemic measures does the covet-19
response team
in any way supervise this process in the
region you may have noticed one detail
if you've been paying attention
in the spring when president putin held
almost daily video conference calls on
coronavirus with heads of research
centers
scientists and virologists he knew them
all by name
and he talked to them in such a manner
that suggested his deep involvement
like remember what you told me yesterday
on the phone and you said this and that
and that
you mean the president used to call each
of them talk to every director of a
research institute
you see the president always prefers to
examine a problem thoroughly
especially when dealing with such
serious challenges to know the science
behind it
and to take decisions based on this
knowledge i'm sure that sergey subbanen
does the same
i just hear that i don't have an issue
with mr saban
it's all pretty clear to me as far as
he's concerned what do you mean
an issue i mean questions i don't have
questions about us competence you said
that governors are now entitled to make
decisions at their own discretion
we have the mayor of moscow who has to
deal with the highest number of
infections in the country on the one
hand
and on the other hand we have the
governor of the region of hakasia
do you really think that the latter is
competent enough to take the right
decisions on his own
listen different people react to what is
happening now
and it is nothing short of an emergency
situation with the pandemic
unfolding in the country in different
ways all the governors have a different
capacity
different teams and infrastructure
different economic capabilities
you can't compare just any region to
moscow moscow does stand out
one thing is obvious everyone is doing
their best to learn how to tackle this
situation
to work on the problems the setbacks
they are facing
do we maintain any communication with
our foreign partners on the pandemic
response
does the kremlin or the international
community have any idea when this whole
thing might finally end
you've probably noticed that in every
news piece about putin's telephone
conversations with his counterparts
there is a line that says that different
aspects of the pandemic response
have been discussed this topic is on the
agenda every time putin speaks
to any of his foreign partners because
covet 19 is a problem that we all
share for some countries it's even more
urgent than for us
we closely cooperate internationally in
terms of exchanging information
also we co-operate on the issue of our
vaccine
we are promoting it to other markets we
are currently discussing possible
production of the vaccine in other
countries
and here in russia naturally for a
nationwide vaccination campaign we need
to provide as many as 150 million units
to cover our domestic needs only
you're absolutely right first of all we
need to meet domestic demand
then we will start supplies to our
partners
yesterday vladimir putin said the
vaccine should be available to everyone
absolutely that's why we are engaged in
ongoing discussions on that matter
you also asked when this pandemic could
end i think no one in the whole world
can give you an answer
from the scientific perspective
virologists say that it will end
when we develop herd immunity that means
70 of the global population needs to
catch covet 19 and recover
or they should get vaccinated okay i see
we need to produce 150 million shots and
make the vaccination widely available
so when do we plan to start mass
production and when do we expect to
launch a sweeping vaccination campaign
sweeping vaccination is out of the
question
it's all strictly voluntary we
reiterated that many times
vaccination will only be done on a
voluntary basis
we are starting production it's a matter
of days or weeks
how much will we be producing that's a
different question
obviously we will be building up our
production capacity as we go
we have some untapped resources the
russian pharmaceutical industry has made
a huge leap forward
over the past 15 years it has become a
competitive industry
and of course pharmaceutical companies
are now capable of taking emergency
steps
to ramp up production of certain
medications when do you think mass
vaccination will kick off
i can't say i simply don't know but it
will start soon in the coming months
you have drawn my attention to the fact
that cover 19 modality rate in russia is
lower than in the us
why is that first of all the death toll
in russia is lower
due to the preventative measures which
are after all effective at curbing the
spread of the infection
which measures in particular the
restrictive measures that were
introduced
face masks and so on and so forth and
then in the u.s
there are mass protests rallies etc
so you are against demonstrations i mean
they don't observe hygiene rules there
oh i see and in russia everyone follows
these rules yes people are more
disciplined in russia
in this regard and that's why our
mortality rate is lower
no i wouldn't put it this way it's too
simplistic
but in general russia's healthcare
system has proved to be more
and in what way do you think our
healthcare has proved to be more
prepared for the pandemic
it's just different russia's healthcare
system is radically different from what
they have in the us
and it turns out that in the case of a
pandemic russian healthcare is doing
better
is delivering healthcare services or
other care more effectively
right and why is that are hospitals
better in russia than in florida
when you interview minister murashko
next time you can ask him all these
questions
i am afraid that the tone of my
conversation with mr roshko will be very
different
anyway thank you you are so bloodthirsty
yes i am thank you mr pisco for this
interview thank you